all right gucci
gucci supreme gucci uh where'd you go
where are you from originally originally
i was born in washington but i'm from
california based california area
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad yeah mom and dad we
had our differences growing up i was the
first american born
so i did a lot of stuff that they didn't
technically
like where's your family from um from
korea
yeah so
but our differences aside now that i'm
getting a little older i
would like to go back and try to patch
things up
but sometimes in life
you
go i'm trying to go forward
and everything else will follow you know
everything all the loose ends will tie
back up and my life will be great
your uh your family was
strict or
um they worked a lot like um i would say
like
um
in my culture they work a lot
so i was mainly home and yeah they were
like strict as in like you know have to
get good grades at a certain point
but you know and sometimes it doesn't go
that way
you know just you have to you have to
pay bills and you have to work so
your childhood was was
event free or were there things going on
that
um well based on my family um in in any
life in any family you know you have
your turmoils in life that you
go through as a child and you grow up
and then you realize that your parents
are humans too and they make mistakes
along the way and um now that i'm old
enough to realize that
no one's perfect and people make
mistakes in life
so
yeah
and what kind of good were you in high
school huh what kind of kid were you in
high school in high school i was more of
a
i was like
i was more of a type of person that
adapted my life with all different all
different types of people like i never
really just stayed with one group
so
um i tried to stay in the asian group
but it was just all grades and i just
wanted to
go outside that box and um i grabbed i
gravitated to a lot of different
lifestyles and life like in like kids
you know like different
like the rock group the prep kids the
um the asians i got good grade group the
punk rock group the
yeah so i just
wanted to be
in like i want all the groups to be all
together
as one after high school you did what um
after high school i um
ended up i ended up getting kicked out
and then i became a stripper and i just
became
like the streets became my lifestyle so
this is in this is in your personality
yeah and it was at an early age yeah at
an early age and um are you the black
sheep of your family yeah i'm the black
sheep
every every family has that i would say
everyone has at least one black sheep of
the family or would it be called a
family i don't think
yeah that's pretty common isn't it yeah
yeah and
so you started working at a strip club
yeah i started like i started out on the
streets first and i i went to the strip
club
um
yeah i adapted myself very well there i
liked dancing and i liked um
engaging with people
and um yeah and having fun
you know so
might as well get paid while having fun
and did that transition into
working as a prostitute
um yeah i think it coincides with one
another yeah i mean very often the strip
clubs double as yeah opportunities for
the girls to make more money yeah so
like in the back rooms and like it comes
together it's like you know unison
you're out walking around two-piece
top off occasionally so you know it it's
hand-in-hand with one another
and your and your family knows about
what you do
um
no not necessarily not necessarily
what would you say to them if they found
out
um i would say that i made mistakes in
my life and if they
you know had their hands arms open i
could be
the person that they wanted me to be
like mentally like being strong and
being more wringlingly
willingly to
be accepted in my family
like
did you do you think there was something
in your upbringing that
made you the black sheep of the family
or you just it's just the way you're
born i think it was
i think it has a lot to do with
um
just being the first american born like
you're just more
in tuned with what america has to offer
you in life and what america
like kids do you know you go out you go
drinking you might occasionally do drugs
here and there but not not all american
kids turn out to be strippers and
prostitutes well yeah not all kids per
se because their parents were there like
holding their hand
and trying to teach them like maybe you
shouldn't do this way maybe you should
do it that way or here i have a business
or you could go into this or you could
learn from me or you know some some kids
are very fortunate and some kids aren't
yeah so one day i want to make a
non-profit organization for kids in the
streets
um so i could help other
kids or people that are going through
hardships in life to turn
to turn to be better or you know to be
better to be the best at what you are or
what you want to do at the time
so
working as a prostitute started for you
how long ago
oh it started on and off since like in
my like 18 19 years um it was like on
and off kind of thing for me i'm gonna
go to the strip club i'll do
um and then gradually i'll meet guys and
of course guys always want something
from you
for me and they always want one thing so
it's like if you want something for me i
definitely want something from you so it
doesn't you know that thing's for free
so if you know you want something for me
i definitely want something from you
so it's a transaction
yeah well not only that it's a it's a
transition in life like if a guy looks
at you and be like oh i want you for
your parts well i want you for something
that makes the world go around i want
your money then right since my parts
make your world go around your money
makes my world go around
and do you recall your first time doing
this for money that i mean did you like
the light bulb go off in your head
saying wow this is great a new way to
make money um
it's like a light bulb but then you know
with that light bulb it comes with other
stuff like in your head you know it's
more of like people do it for free all
the time they go to bars and clubs they
get drunk wake up and wake up next to
this person and be like what's your name
and they'd like get out like i don't
remember what happened last night and i
think that's more traumatizing to
anybody else like just waking up
realizing oh you know so
yeah
so so currently you'll work the internet
or the track the streets yeah i do um
whatever makes me money i try to mix it
up yeah like i'll try to you know
whatever is there and um yeah i can make
money out of it then i will
then you do this on your own or with a
pimp i do it on my own
yeah
it's uh you keep the money that way
do you have any friends
um i do have friends but um i tend to
not open up to them like i really don't
have friends let me change that i really
don't
i tend to like keep to myself because in
this business you can't have friends
yeah because you know the more they know
the more they're going to throw at you
do you have children
do i have children no no children how
old are you i am 32 32. yeah you still
have time yeah
did you have
dreams or goals of doing something with
your life when you were younger um i
think we all have those like
since that question's based on me yes um
growing up i always wanted to be
a productive person in life
um that's why i want to transition my
life into
doing a non-profit organization and
making it um
to help help back you know
that's the least i could do
change things
for the best of my
compatible you know
at least make my family proud that i'm
doing something
something positive in this something
positive could come out of this
that'd be nice do you think do you think
the asian culture
has a difficult time
dealing with
one of their own doing this kind of work
um yeah i would say that because a lot
of people view us as like oh they have
money they have um
they have a but
but that technically
money doesn't buy happiness money
doesn't buy your character money doesn't
buy your mentals money doesn't build you
it could break you too you know it's the
way you do things like especially in the
asian community
seasons change and people change their
minds and um yeah it's just how what
what you're going to do at the end with
it you know that's how i look at it
because people judge all the time
and i just want to
like i really don't care what people
think of me
or
per se like
what they want me to be because
in my eyes i'm going to be the best
person i could be
and be the most um
outstanding person i could be whatever i
like i do
and right now is making money and i'm
going to be the best person at it
and i've learned that you have to be you
have to put your both feet forward and
be the best person at it at the moment
that you're in it so there's no shame
for you no shame
um in life i think in anything you
choose to do shame a little bit of shame
comes with everything no matter what you
choose to do in life
so um you just gotta you know
put a smile on and just move forward you
know life goes on and daylight comes out
every day so
a new day does doing sex work affect you
emotionally
um i think it affects me in a way of how
men could look at you like and like i
feel like sex work makes you feel like
you're like an object and i and i look
at money as an object like money is my
motive
to overcome that you know because guys
always look at me and be like oh can i
have
you know your can i have like they just
want sex like asian face sex you know so
it's like if that motivates you money
motivates me
so that's that's that's the kind of
attitude that i have is is doing this
kind of work affected the way you
interact with men outside of the outside
of the
the sex work you do i think it makes me
more
more i think i figured out who i am more
in that way in that sense because i know
how that guy
mind is because they only want one thing
and like you know and
i don't think it defines me as a person
or my character
um i just want to be the best at it like
just you know are all men this way
um not all men
but
isn't that how men work
you're the man you should because
biologically there's some truth in what
you're saying i think yeah like that but
there are certain certain men that maybe
can well there are
men i think there's a difference when
you're timid in your
and you're trying i i figure out right
now in the life that we live in at this
time time
some guys are in turmoils with
themselves yeah you know maybe they
don't know who they are maybe they don't
sex don't drive them you know no i don't
know if it's about being timid
it might have
more to do with just you know having
your head and heart in the right place
yeah not all guys are controlled by
their
their urges no you're you're but but
urges are a part of biology and it's
part of being human yeah so my
experiences in life i probably met a
couple guys are not about it but mostly
they are the guys you're meeting working
as a prostitute or a stripper you're
gonna or even going into a regular store
they look at me like you know like let's
have fun you know
so
yeah
do you find being asian makes
you more attractive more uh desirable in
the field that you're in
i don't like this whole asian thing i
know i'm asian um but
um
i don't think i'm
like a lot i'm not sure about that
question
i'm not sure yeah good i mean
i don't know if you were a figaro street
but like on figaro it's there's like the
exoticness yeah
you would stand out yeah yeah i stand
out
yeah i would think that'd be a benefit
[Music]
and the first question is are you the
police it's like no definitely not it's
because i'm you're right because i'm the
only
you know the only one
i've seen an asian girl up and down fig
i've seen other asian girls too have you
yeah i've seen other asian girls here
and there here and there
so yeah there's a lot of white girls a
lot of mexican and tons of african
american yeah
but things in life will change for the
better for all of us
you know
what was the best relationship you ever
saw of a loving relationship between a
man and a woman uh my grandparents your
grandparents my grandparents and they're
like my
i always wanted to find that kind of
love but being in the streets i've
learned that there is no love like you
know
so have you been in love before
of course yeah of course i've i've been
in love but in life i've learned that
you have to love yourself
and other
in order for other people to love you
um so
yeah
it seems like the asian culture
they aim
the
the bar is set very high for their
children yeah it is and and i wonder
if you feel or if your family feels like
you're
letting yourself down or you're
disappointing them or something of
course of course i feel that way um
especially at my age now but i'll be
disappointing myself if i started
something and i didn't finish it so
at my age i should be
looking for my future and i don't want
to start something and not finish it i i
i would
categorize most americans
most
north americans as very uptight about
sex
yeah most not all but sex is a natural
thing yeah right right it's human yeah
it's human i think the asian community
is as well
yeah well
i don't want to per se talk for the
asian culture like i guess i guess we're
all humans
and um
you know we all operate the same way i
would hope
so i i you know yeah so
like i love my community i love my
culture but i would want them to accept
you know like because you're right like
you don't really see a lot of asians
walking on fig or walking around and you
know we're crazy to them probably
but
what can we what can i do about it now i
started so young and
you know
yeah and being a stripper was you know
fun so
you enjoy your work yeah i do
there's some down there's some downsides
to it too but you you enjoy the upsides
of it yeah the fast money the fast money
the fast money does it make you feel
does it boost your self-esteem or does
it break it down
doing this kind of work um it's both
it builds my confiscating but then
breaks me down because then i i always
like look at my past and see why i could
change you know and then like all my
heart aches that i've been through in my
childhood like with my family and stuff
i wish i could change that i wish i
could change um relationships i had in
my life i wish i could be i wish i could
have been the best best at it like i
wish i could have been my fullest
potential but sometimes you know i did
do drugs and it kind of
altered my thinking and altered my frame
it it went it took me to a dark dark
space that i wouldn't want people to go
in it was really dark for a while are
drugs a part of your life um it was it
was a part of my life um on and off um
what were you playing around with um
just coke molly meth um
yeah and i drank alcohol occasionally
um
just to
just to like
have like a mask
you know i wanted to mask things in my
life
because i'm
i'm like a i'm like a
nurturer like nurture with people and
stuff like that so it just comes
naturally yeah but i would think you
know
working a strip club
dating strangers on the street whatever
you're doing
a little alcohol or something in your
system might make it a lot easier yeah
yeah
but now i just want to be clear-headed
and
you know be the best at it as i could be
are you lonely
um yeah i'm occasionally lonely i think
we all can say that like as being humans
like how are you just 100 content yeah
every day all day you know you're just
like i'm content i'm never lonely i'm
never sad i think this lifestyle
probably
has a
predominance of lonely
women that you would think wouldn't be
lonely because they're dating all these
guys but they end up
yeah a lot of them tell me they're
lonely well i would say like a lot of
these girls like i'm talking about
myself too like i've been molested when
i was younger i had dad issues in and
out of my life so like
i think that was a little bit of
like
okay well then if i'm gonna if i got
molested at this young of age
what's sex to me yeah you know do you
feel like being
abused sexually as a child kind of
opened the door for
well a lot of traumas sex work yeah it's
like the first trigger
you know like so it's more it's it's
easier for you to have like this mask on
where it's
not hurting you
you know so you just put it up you put
the wall up
yeah
what is the hardest part of doing this
kind of work for you the hardest part
part of me is being accepted
i think
i think it's because of my culture like
it's just being accepted
but i don't care you know like now at
this point it's like if you accept me
you accept me if you don't then you
don't you know like i'm just gonna be
you know
just be good at it
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work i think the misunderstood thing
is
um
i think a lot of people would have to be
in pain
and go through a lot of stuff in life
in order to put their walls up you know
it takes a lot and it takes a lot of
courage
so i give it up to the girls that could
do it because i do it you know so
yeah
it gets better
do you find uh doing this kind of work
is uh you've changed since you've been
doing it yeah i change i just like to be
positive about things and um
yeah the only thing you could do is look
forward
because once you start looking backwards
you're going to really feel bad about
yourself you got to just move forward
just in life in general and your clients
are
single married
i get all different types um
yeah i have all different types of
clients
and i love it you know i love making
people happy that we're sad
or
frustrated they do their frustrations
out
you know
you know like
it makes me happy
i take one less predator out the streets
that's a great way of seeing it
yeah
do you ever have bad things happen to
you
um yeah bad things happen to me but i
didn't it wasn't built who i am today
those bad experiences i try to put a
happy face on
um but believe me sometimes in closed
doors i do cry a lot
but um but it turns into happiness the
frown could stay frown so
long that frown is eventually going to
turn to a smile and your smile is going
to stay up
you don't see yourself as a victim
of course my in life you can't look at
yourself as a victim well that's how
people do that well i've been through
that stage where it was just like my mom
my dad my family my relationships in
life poor me but it's like at the end of
the day
it's not poor you
you know because you wouldn't be that
person you are today if you if you were
that person if you weren't going through
what you've been through in life it's a
great attitude yeah
are you think you're addicted to this
life
um i think i'm just addicted to money
you're fast money i think i'm just
addicted to the money
do you think you deserve a better life
than than this
i think we all do
you're probably right
like the richest people have
things that they go through you know
like we all deserve a better life at one
point money doesn't make you all happy
you know it's not just mental it's just
not money it's mental it's it's um you
know it's just about taking care of
yourself i realized are are there
certain personality traits a woman needs
in order to do this kind of work or can
anybody do it if they just get over the
initial hump of the like i said before i
think it comes with a lot of things that
you've been through in life and if you
could if you could swallow it because a
lot of people
they can't swallow it you know and if
you can't swallow it then you can't take
it
and um i've realized that because i let
my asian community mess with that for a
while like oh can i or are they going to
judge me but at the end of the day i
don't care
because i'm still
i'm still going to wake up with myself
i'm going to still look in the mirror
and look at me i'm going to look at my
face i think we both just had a couple
of unintended puns there
what advice would you give to a woman
who's thinking about doing this kind of
work i would say
um
just look in the mirror and be sure of
yourself and be know
know who you are
you would you wouldn't say no don't do
this
um it's to each their own if they want
to
so go ahead you know it's that's what
they want to do
like who am i to say no don't do
something and i enjoy it i like doing it
i love meeting men i love meeting people
and i love turning frustrations into a
positive thing i like to talk to people
you know and maybe they had a bad day
maybe they want to talk to me about oh
their relationships in life and i'm here
i'll talk to you and we'll talk through
it you know i'll be your therapist for
the moment too do you know yeah just
turning a positiveness out of it because
everyone goes through things in life you
know i'm pretty sure all the guys that
go out there looking for a girl they're
going through something yeah so and and
it goes
you know it goes the same way it's just
life it's called life
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your the most
important thing i've learned
is
i can't go back but family is everything
um i can't go back because you're right
it's like an asian community kind of
thing like they really do is your family
kind of like
how is your relationship with your
family now not good i try to call them
they're not answering
but um hopefully one day they'll come
around and accept me because i surely
accept them
and i'm accepting myself
excellent all right gucci thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you i
wish you the best of luck out there yeah
your attitude's very refreshing
thank you thank you very much yeah
you